The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So for
today we're just
going to break you
guys up into groups.
So Kenneth and Andrea, you
guys can work together today
for the rest of class.
Paul, Ulea, and David.
Since we have an
odd numbers, there's
going to be a group of three.
And then Nathan and Joshua,
you guys can film each other.
And I know that you're
going to be a little bit
limited with locations today.
So if you wanted to
film on location,
you might not be able
to do that for today.
But just get
comfortable with, like,
the movements of the camera,
incorporating the stuff
Chris talked about earlier.
That's what we want
you guys to do today.
And break!
Go team!
[MANY STUDENTS TALKING]
MALE SPEAKER: In the year
2009, famous astrophysicist
Stephen Hawking and actually
hosted a [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: So,
like, just shoot.
MALE SPEAKER: The goal
I'm trying to get you
and the-- You're
grabbing that, right?
MALE SPEAKER: No, because
this should be in.
MALE SPEAKER: Through
all sorts of [INAUDIBLE].
Even [INAUDIBLE].
But absolutely no one came.
MALE SPEAKER: Just
go [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, that sucks.
MALE SPEAKER: So that
was all in my shot.
MALE SPEAKER: I
mean this could be
had if they're going [INAUDIBLE]
half a second shock response.
MALE SPEAKER: Or in the
couch or where they are.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, I'm sorry.
Where are they.
MALE SPEAKER: Since it
should be [INAUDIBLE].
You would grab some
water, grab one,
pour the water, [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: So like, I'm
kind of like-- [INAUDIBLE]